e aí gente
bom a gente vai aproveitar que a gente
está num estoque nunca achei que está
acontecendo na minha vida é pra assim
além de tocar uma música só um pouco
sobre que são essas músicas antes porque
a gente tá tocando elas essa primeira
música é uma música que eu fiz pra irmã
mais nova da minha ex namorada que no
caso era uma criança na época e no
terminal me toquei que eu não ia mais
velha eu era pequeno então não sei que
ela vai achar de mim não sei o que vai
ser daqui pra frente
enfim se houver essa música se chama
sofia
[Música]
tá pra ver pela janela barris a gear
aquarela menina e as flores no jardim
[Música]
vou chegando devagar ela começa a me
olha é odil algo mais ou menos assim
[Música]
sorria sófia
mas quando você hein
mundo em um rio de volta pras o fim a um
dia você pode esquecer de mais água
eu nunca vou te esquecer
[Música]
nem sempre há a agravada panin nem
sempre o santos vai ter essa mas sofia
acreditem em mim só ro nasce com
promessa de uma vida sem pressa viva
agora nunca pense na finn sorri hahn
safia
mas quando você riu mundo inteiro rio de
volta traz à fia um dia
você pode esquecer de ninguém mais saiba
que eu nunca vou te esquece tem tim
chegar além do que é fácil ver não é
preciso e nagy na quando pode apenas ser
e deixa a vida acontecer alguns dentes
vão cair desafios vão surgir mas isso é
crescer sorrir
a sofia pois quando você e edmundo em
rio de volta pras o fim a um dia você
pode esquecer de mim mas saiba que eu
nunca vou te esquece essa primeira
música ai gente então dando continuidade
ao bloco do rock show e teve músicas
músicas com nomes próprios nas pessoas
sua próxima música se chama inês inês
foi uma tia avó minha que faleceu aos
dois anos atrás mais ou menos
foi a primeira experiência do tipo que
eu tive mesmo com morte próximo assim a
família e sempre fica aquela dúvida mas
aqui vai ser agora sim fui
fora isso você só tem a dúvida ea
ausência não é bom
acesse foi e eu fiquei o que vai ser de
mim eu não sei estou tentando seguir em
frente mas assim contracorrente acho que
eu me afogar que me está a imaginar como
seria passar mais uns dias com você vê o
sol na série soee coisas que afasta e
diz que você sair daqui
[Música]
mas só de virar mais uma vez se não for
será que brilha onde está e nem já não
sei mais alguns dias atrás eu sabia eu
sabia
venha me tirar de se safar porque eu não
quero mais ficar onde nes não está sabiá
vim aqui cantar pra mim porque tá tudo
do inglês desde que ela é a shin as
praias do rio noto mais as gaivotas não
pousam mais nos caixotes
os carros deixaram as marginais e até o
tempo parece andar pra trás sem você
é mas só admirar mais uma vez se não for
será que brilha onde está e mail não sei
mais alguns dias atrás eu sabe
[Música]
eu sabe venha me inspirar e se safar
porque eu não aguento mais ficar onde
nes não está sabiá tem aqui cantar pra
mim porque tá tudo tão ruim desde que
ela a china
[Música]
obrigado valeu mesmo gente abraça uma
música aqui fala sobre não tá no bbb
assim é que a gente toca de vez em
quando nos acústicos tem oportunidade né
ela fala sobre nada no fundo fala um
pouco assim ela significa muito para mim
justíssimo é e se chama na contramão e
essas coisas vão e vêm
o vento vai levar e me leva também para
algum lugar além do mais como é que dão
seus pais não sei foi há tanto tempo
atrás que eu nem lembro se foi fevereiro
ou se for exemplo o rio de janeiro eu
vou seguir vivendo os maiores medos
alguns deles reais outros tops a deus
os carros na marginal me lembro de um
carnaval que já passou a viver um grande
amor é coisa de cinema
não vou pagar pra ver
eu não não sabe o sol só aquelas mesmas
mentiras banhadas informou
e aqui entre o sal o chão
vendo maleta girar na contra mão se
vocês se vou chorar sentir a sepultar
essa dor que me dá algum sentido pra
cantar de novo esse refrão que já passou
por que viver um grande amor
2 ed cinema e eu não vou pagar pra eu
não
adoro vos olha só quero as mesmas
mentiras banha o mall e eu aqui entre o
céu eo chão
vendo planeta girar na contra-mão na
contra mão
[Música]
é isso aí valeu a isso não tem muita
oportunidade de tocar essa música então
quando da gente a gente sempre bota no
site bom essa última música aí estampada
aí a falar um pouco sobre a general que
tem a cabeça de grilo e que é totalmente
estranho falar um pouco sobre ela quando
ser feitas no futuro dá nome ao ao nosso
ip dá nome ao clipe que a gente lançou
galera se quiserem dar uma olhada
é o meio maluco assim o que ele fala
sobre o embate de dois super heróis é
sobre quem quer ser o herói da cidade
eles não não ligam muito branco o que
eles fazem de bom mas na verdade quem
vai salvar as pessoas na cidade ou seja
o ego por trás do do heroísmo é um
negócio que a gente gosta muito de falar
não necessariamente sobre a gente queria
mudar o mundo mas a gente fala da
hipocrisia de querer salvar o mundo se
uma motivo tão egoísta que acompanha com
ele pessoas cegas e valorizam sim sempre
falando várias coisas no ponto
[Música]
escute quer eu digo eu já cansei
chegou a hora de descer cima desse muro
acredite quando eu digo que eu sei que o
meu presente pra você mudar nosso futuro
é tudo muito novo eo mal cheguei aí no
mundo amargurado que cansou de cercado
cup saiba que ama tem shakira lei ora
agora o progresso que eu procuro eu sou
eu sou eu sou eu eo quem vai mudar 11
sou eu sou eu sou eu que quero falar no
fixo hro sou eu sou eu sou eu
[Música]
sou eu sou eu sou eu que canta escolhe
seguro
[Música]
sim mas bagão bate ou se mude as amarras
que mantinha já não são mais tão seguras
livro somas não te iludem o herói saiu
da trama e vague a sua loucura
rapaz eu conquistei me casei vazia mas
eu transformo distribuem entre muro e
saiba que eu vou te deixa que o teu lei
ora agora vem mudando o futuro sou eu
sou eu sou eu quem vai mudar o mundo
[Música]
sou eu sou eu sou surdo
sou eu só sou eu sou eu que consigo
diego muro uhuuu
[Música]
eu sei eu sei eu sei mas ao dar num sei
eu sei eu sei que quero falar o fim de
sururu sei eu sei é assim
sou eu sou eu sou elo herói do teu
futuro
ele não é obrigado galera
esse foi o pacote show que a gente
preparou na verdade espero que vocês
tenham gostado das músicas mais ser
convidado para ouviu e pena integra
assim é bem diferente disso aqui tipo
essa baterista na real é isso é isso aí
obrigado a todos obrigado pela
oportunidade
então toda a organização aí fiquei muito
feliz em tocar isso aí temos um passo
que agradeceu a esperança instituição
maravilhosa aqui no caso do estudante
pelo espaço pela palestra sempre
promovem eventos incríveis a todo mundo
que organizou a todos os palestrantes
muito obrigado estamos na briga e é isso
[Aplausos]
[Música]